what's up everyone
Mike McCarty here with a GameSpot news
update developer Treyarch has shed a
little more light on why black ops 3 DS
campaign didn't make it into the last
gen versions of the game in a recent
interview creative director jason
blundell said the power of the last
generation machines was simply not
enough to deliver an uncompromised
version of what Trey art had in mind for
4 player co-op in the interview with
official Xbox Magazine blundell said
let's imagine I have my customized
weapons for you as a co-op player to see
what weapon I have you have to have
loaded in every single weapon
customization in the memory current gen
memory just can't do that you have to
have everything loaded otherwise you
just can't see what I'm carrying
blundell also said it would have been
possible to simplify things but this
could have had its own downsides as well
he went on to say I think Activision
made the right choice because I would
hate for people to get an experience
that wasn't true to the vision of it as
the director I'm incredibly passionate
about the experience being a pure one
the last gen versions of black ops 3 in
development at V Knox and mercenary
technology will run at 30fps compared to
60fps on new generation systems NTC
which are both being developed by
Treyarch black ops 3 for Xbox 360 and
ps3 launches November 6th alongside the
new gen and PC editions it comes with a
free copy of the original Call of Duty
Black Ops and sell for $50 instead of
the current gen $60 price tag well at
least the last gen version isn't
retailing at full price but if you are a
huge call duty fan it might be time to
make the jump to current gen for more
news and our review on black ops 3 stay
tuned to Gamescom
[Music]